cool star l'offre en matière de visites
guidées s'est considérablement
diversifié ces dernières années les
visiteurs qui veulent sortir des
sentiers battus ont l'embarras du choix
les gens ils veulent une relation plus
intime une relation plus unique avec les
destinations dans lesquelles ils vont et
à montréal ben ça se passe à travers les
visites gourmandes à depuis huit ans
cette entreprise propose ce type de
visite à montréal québec et toronto une
activité destinée aux touristes
étrangers mais pas seulement on soit à
se soigner et des locaux et je trouve
que les locaux se soient les plus
intéressants parce qu'on peut même
pousser un peu plus loin parce qu'ils
ont des informations qui se connaissent
déjà surtout si on parle politique au
niveau de la société dessert
c'est ce que surtout dans une ville
comme signal de quartier du mile end
mais le côté artistique on parle d'une
murale on va parler de la communauté par
exemple arcade fire qui a été fondée ici
donc oui on fait des liens avec ça c'est
sûr que l'homme à une nourriture culture
l'histoire et qu'on essaie de tout
mélanger
durant trois heures les participants
découvrent quartier à travers ses
saveurs
la nourriture c'est quelque chose qui
rassemble c'est quelque chose qui nous
unit tous
ouais on fait clairement des liens qui
ont passé trois heures avec un guide à
pied dans un quartier l'organisme
héritage montréal propose des circuits
pour découvrir ou re découvrir des
trésors montréalais le patrimoine n'est
pas juste un objet qu'on met sous une
cloche de verre c'est pas un artefact
d'un patrimoine qui se vit à tous les
jours et donc quand on connaît mieux ce
patrimoine on a envie de le protéger
puis on a envie de s'y intéresser
davantage les circuits qui permettent de
sillonner les quartiers est de voir
comment l'évolution des lieux de travail
a influencé l'architecturé
l'organisation urbaine de la métropole
plusieurs ensembles industriels
puissants son kill qui accueillait des
ouvriers et des ouvrières dans le passé
ah tiens maintenant des artistes d des
entreprises créatives dangereusement
patrie à beaucoup d'artistes se sont
établies par exemple dans l'ancienne
usine catelli dans l'enseigné in
cadburry proche d'ici également des
plates formes en ligne permet aux
internautes de s'offrir des visites très
ni chez l'artiste vit rona sorenson
propose régulièrement des visites
artistique durant lesquels les
participants sont invités à dessiner
c'est vraiment un dialogue avec deux
artistes l'intérieur qui est là dans
tout le monde avec un parti de le monde
autour de lui même ce ne sont que
quelques exemples des nombreux circuits
touristiques qui permettent de se
dépayser sans trop s'éloigner de la
maison ici nabi alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal
[Musique]